สวัสดีครับครูเรียนสวัสดีค่ะครูนิกโอเค
แล้วก็สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับ
สวัสดีค่ะเ
เย้สบายดีใช่มยครูเรียนสบายดีค่ะครูนี้
ตอนนี้ก็แดดส่องมาที่หน้ารู้สึกแบบหน้า
แบบสว่าง
มากฉ่ำนะสุขภาพดีไงใช่แต่อาจจะแบบเหมือน
ผิวสแทนอีกครึ่งนึงแล้วก็แบบอันนี้อีก
ครึ่งนึงเพราะแดดมันส่องเยอะใช่มั้ยใช่ๆ
ทุกวันนี้หน้าเลียมก็ยังสีไม่เท่ามือเลย
นะทำไมล่ะไม่แต่เวลาแบบปกตินะเพราะคครู
นี้ก็เป็นเหมือน
กันหรอเวลาขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์ออกจากบ้านใช่
มั้ยเราก็จะใส่หมวกกันน็อคแล้วเราก็จะแบบ
บางทีเราคิดว่าอุ๊ยวันนี้แบบแดดไม่มี
เลียมก็ไม่ใส่เสื้อแขนยาวไงใส่เสื้อแขน
สั้นอเนี่ยแล้วก็ออก
ไปแล้วพอออกไปจริงๆ
อ้าวแดดร้อนมาก
ใช่พูดถึงขับมอเตอร์ไซค์อ่ะครูนิกเคยนะ
เคยเอ่อกลับไปบ้านแม่ที่ลำพูนแล้วก็ไม่มี
อะไรทำก็ขับมอเตอร์ไซค์พอขับมอเตอร์ไซค์
ทั้งวันนะมันไม่รู้สึกว่าร้อนแต่มันมีแดด
แต่คือเวลาขับมอเตอร์ไซค์มันเร็วไงแล้วลม
มันก็พักตลอดแล้วก็เออก็อากาศดีนะพอกลับ
ถึงบ้านอาบน้ำแสบมากเพราะว่ามันไหม้ผิว
ไหม้ใช่คก็ไหม้นะเนี่ยใช่อือแต่ของคุนิก
อ่ะพอมันไหม้เนี่ยมันเหมือนมันของคุนิก
อาจจะโชคดีพอมันไหม้มันจะเปลี่ยนเป็นสี
ปกติเร็วอือืของเรียนเปลี่ยนช้ามากเนี่ย
อย่างที่เห็น
น่ะคือแบบเป็นคนผิว 2
สีเพื่อนของครูนิกเป็นเหมือนกันเค้าไปไหน
ไม่รู้นะครูนิกจำไม่ได้ก็ตรงเนี้ยดำตรง
เนี้ย
ขาว 3 ปี
อ่ะ 3 ปีนะกว่าจะหายใช่แต่เไม่เป็นไรหรอก
เรียมไม่เครียดแล้วแหละคูณนิกพูดแบบนี้
เรียมก็สบายใจแล้วแหละเดี๋ยวจะไม่ทำอะไร
เลยจริงๆครูนิก็อยากผิวสีแทนนะครูนิกไม่
ชอบผิวสีขาผิวแบบอย่างเงี้ยครุณนิกอยาก
ให้ผิวสีแทนครูนิกชอบไปอาบแดดออใช่จริง
อรอแล้วแบบครูนิกแบบผิวสีแทนอยู่ได้นาน
มยมากที่สุดครูนิกจำได้เนี่ย 2 เดือนอ๋อ
ก็นานอยู่นะก็คืออาบแดด 1 ครั้งใช่มั้ยคะ
ใช่แต่แต่จริงๆ 1 ครั้งก็ไม่ใช่เพราะว่า
เมื่อก่อนที่ครูนิกอาบแดดเนี่ยครูนิกจะ
อาบแดดอาทิตย์ละ 1 ครั้งแล้วถ้าเกิดว่า
สมมุติประมาณ 2-3 ครั้งอ่ะครับแล้วมันก็
จะอยู่ได้ประมาณ 2 เดือน
อืใช่ๆเรมรู้สึกว่าเวลาที่แบบเราเจอแดด
อ่ะแล้วแบบเรมรู้สึกแบบมีพลังอ่ะอืมเออ
รู้สึกแบบ
เอ้ยมีพลังแต่ถ้าเกิดวันไหนที่ฝนตกฟ้า
ครึ้มเราก็จะรู้สึกแบบออไม่ค่อยดีรู้สึก
แบบอือ
เ้อเศร้า
จังแต่เวลาครูนิกอาบจริงๆเนี่ยครูนิกชอบ
อาบแดดเพราะว่าครูนิกอยากมีผิวสีแทนที่
ไม่ใช่สีนี้นะให้มันสีมันมืดกว่านี้หน่อย
อืแล้วก็เวลาอาบแดดเนี่ยคุณนิจะอาบแดดบน
เวลาไปทะเลหรือว่าไปเที่ยวแล้วมันมีสระ
ว่ายน้ำแล้วมันไม่มีหลังคาหลังคาไม่มีอ
คุณนิก็จะอาบแดดประมาณ 2
ชมงอื
หูก็นอนนอนแล้วแบบคุณนิกได้ทำอะไรไปด้วย
มยแบบทำก็คุนิก็จะอ่านหนังสือและฟังเพลง
พร้อมๆกันนะเดี๋ยวๆๆอ่านหนังสือแล้วก็ฟัง
เพลงใช่แล้วก็อาบแดดใช่อ๋อก็ทำได้นะทำได้
ทำได้คือคุณนิกคูณนิกจะแปลกนะเพราะว่าถ้า
อ่านหนังสืออยู่ที่บ้านคนเดียวหรืออยู่ใน
ห้องคนเดียวเนี่ยจะต้องอ่านเงียบๆไม่มี
ต้องไม่ฟังเพลงแต่เวลาไปข้างนอกถ้าอ่าน
หนังสือครูนิกต้องฟังเพลงเพราะว่าถ้าครูู
นิกได้ยินเสียงคนพูดเดินไปมาครูนิกจะอ่าน
หนังสือไม่ได้อ๋อแล้วเพลงที่ครูนิกเปิด
ฟังเนี่ยคือแบบเพลงแบบไหนคะมีมีคนร้อง
เพลงมยมีเ้าเหรองงมยงงริมก็เข้าใจว่าน่า
จะเป็นแบบเพลงคลาสสิคหรือว่าแบบเป็น
เปียโนเออเป็นเพลงเหมือนบรเลงที่ไม่มีคน
ร้องใช่มั้ไม่ใช่
เออแปลก
มากแปลกใช่ป่ะงงแต่ก็ทำได้เนาะแบบเท่าที่
ฟังฟมาเรียมก็ได้ยินว่าครูนิกทั้งอาบแดด
อ่านหนังสือแล้วก็ฟังเพลงไปพร้อมกัน
ใช่ใช่ก็ทำหลายอย่างพร้อมกันเพราะว่าจริง
ๆเี่บางคนน่ะคิดว่าอาบแดดเนี่ยก็
นอนอย่างเดียวไม่ต้องทำอะไรอืแต่ว่าอาบ
แดดเนี่ยเราต้องคิดด้วยนะว่าพอเราอาบแดด
เนี่ยเราจะต้องพลิก
ตัวเหมือนกับเราอาบแดดอย่างเงี้ยเรานอน
คว่ำครึ่งชั่วโมงเนี่ยเราต้องเปลี่ยนนะ
พลิกเหมือนกับว่าให้เรานอนเ่ะหน้าเราอ่ะ
หงายขึ้นมาอืไม่งั้นเนี่ยมันทั้งตัวมันจะ
ไม่ดำ
อ๋ออุ้ยไม่เคยรู้มาก่อนไม่มีประสบการณ์
การอาบแดดถ้าเป็นเลียมนะเลียมก็คงแบบนอน
หลับไปเลยแล้วก็แบบเออเอ่าตื่นขึึ้นมาอ่า
ถ้าครูเรียมนอนหลับยาวไปเลยถ้าครูเรียม
นอนหงายหน้าครูเรียมก็จะดำแต่หลังครู
เรียมก็จะขาวใช่อืโอ้โหอาบแดดมันต้องทำ
มันต้องพลิกตัวด้วยครึ่งชั่วโมง 1 ชมง
หรืออย่างน้อยครับครึ่งชั่วโมงใช่ต้อง
พลิกตัวเหมือนเวลาเราคุณนี้จะชอบคิดว่า
เหมือนเวลาเราย่างปลาหมึกหรือย่างอ่ะมัน
ย่างข้างเดียวมันก็ไม้ข้างเดียวมันต้อง
พลิกพลิกหรอครูนิไม่คิดเหมือนแบบไก่หัน
อะไรงี้เหรอที่แบบเราต้องแบบหมุนไปเรื่อย
ๆถ้าแบบนั้นน่ะเราก็จะเหนื่อยไงเหนื่อย
มันหมุนตลอดอ่ะแดดอ่ะแดดก็จะงงแล้วว่า
เอ๊ะทำ
อะไรแต่อาจจะสวยก็ได้นะอาจจะแบบแต่เราอ่ะ
จะมึนเลยนะเพราะว่าถ้าเราหมุน 1 ช่วโมง
ใช่ๆโอเรมสิ่งนี้เป็นสิ่งที่น่าสนใจมาก
ครูนิกเวลาที่เราทำอะไรหลายๆอย่างในเวลา
เดียวกันอืใช่นั่นแหละเรียมก็เลยคิดว่า
เออจริงๆเนี่ยเรียม
ก็ทำอีก 1 อย่างแล้วก็มีทำอีก 1 อย่างไป
ด้วยกันนะอย่างเช่นเวลาที่เรียมกินข้าว
ใช่มยเรียมก็จะกินข้าวไปด้วยหรือว่าเรียม
ก็ดู YouTube ไปด้วยครับ
เออแล้วบางทีริมก็แบบเออกินข้าวไปก็ไม่
รู้ว่าอร่อยหรือไม่อร่อย
อืเพราะว่ามันมันอาจจะโฟกัสไม่ได้อ่ะิม
ไม่ได้สนใจที่ข้าวนะเรียมสนใจที่ YouTube
แล้วเรียมก็กินอ้าแต่แบบนั้นน่ะครูนิดก็
คิดนะว่าเพราะว่าเวลาบอกว่าทำหลายอย่าง
พร้อม
กันแปลว่าเราเนี่ยต้องโฟกัสทั้ง 2 อย่าง
หรือหลายๆอย่างพร้อมกันคือยกตัวอย่าง
เนี่ยคือแม่ของครูนิกเนี่ยเาชอบเปิดทีวี
แล้วก็ไม่สนใจคือเหมือนเปิดทีวีให้ได้ยิน
เสียงเพราะว่าแม่ครูนิเนี่ยเขาจะเคเวลา
เขาอยู่บ้านคนเดียวเขาจะกลัวแม่คุนิกลัว
ผีอืกลัวเาก็จะชอบเปิดทีวีให้มันมีเสียง
แล้วเก็จะไปทำอย่างอื่นแล้วพอยกตัวอย่าง
ว่าเค้าเปิดทีวีแล้วก็กวาดบ้านก็กวาดๆด
กวาดไปเค้าก็ไม่ได้สนใจว่าทีวีพูดอะไรแต่
ถ้ามันมีเรื่องในทีวีที่เขาสนใจเก็จะหยุด
กวาดบ้านแล้วก็ดูทีวีพอมันจบก็กวาดบ้าน
ต่ออืถ้าแบบนั้นเราจะเรียกว่าทำหลายอย่าง
พร้อมๆกันมก็ทำหลายอย่างนะ
แต่ความจริงแล้วเรียมคิดว่าเราอาจจะโฟกัส
ได้แค่อย่างเดียวแหละแต่มันอาจจะสลับไป
สลับไปที่ทีวีสลับมาที่กวาดบ้านสลับไปที่
ทีวีสลับมาที่กวาดบ้านเออนั่นแหละก็ก็ทำ
ได้นะคะเรมก็คิดว่าหลายๆคนก็ทำแบบนั้น
อืแล้วเรมก็เห็นนะเพื่อนของเรียมเนี่ยขับ
รถครับแล้วเป็นอะไรที่เรียมกลัวมากออื
เค้าขับรถมานานแล้วเค้ารู้สึกว่าโอ๊สบายๆ
ขับรถแล้วแบบเวลาที่แบบมีคนโทรเข้ามา
เงี้ยแล้วก็รับโทรศัพท์อืฮัลโหลขับรถไป
ด้วยคุยโทรศัพท์ไปด้วยแต่เรียมเป็นคนที่
กลัวมากอ่ะครับเวลาคุยโทรศัพท์ในรถอ่ะอื
อืถ้าเกิดแบบแต่ประเทศไทยกฎหมายเค้าให้
ใช้ Small  Talk เนาะใช้ได้ใช่มั้ย
เออประเทศไทยยต้องใช้ Small  Talk แต่แบบ
ให้มาแบบนี้หรือว่าแบบวิดีโอคอไม่ได้อืใช
แต่ก็ยังอันตรายอยู่ดีอันตรายใช่เพราะว่า
คูนิกเนี่ยคุณนิกจะไม่ใช้โทรศัพท์เลยถ้า
ไม่ขับรถจริงๆใช้โทรศัพท์แต่ว่าจะดู
แผนที่ดู Google  Map ว่าเราจะไปที่ไหน
แล้วต้องไปยังไงอืใช่ก็จะเอาเปิดเปิดเปิด
Google  Map ในโทรศัพท์แล้วก็เอาติดเอา
ไว้แล้วเราก็จะมองแผนที่ด้วยมองทางด้วย
แต่จะไม่คุยโทรศัพท์
อ๋อแล้วครูนี้คิดว่าเวลาที่คนเราเนี่ยทำ
อะไรหลายๆอย่างหลายๆอย่างในในเวลาเดียว
กันเนี่ยทำได้มากสุดนี่ครูครูนิกคิดว่า
กี่
อย่างสำหรับครูนิกนะ
ครุนิคิดว่าครุนิคิดว่า 3 อย่างอื 3
อย่างก็คือมากที่สุดละ
อืมเหมือนอาบแดดอ่านหนังสือฟังเพลง
ครับใช่ตัดเล็บตัดเล็บดู
ทีวีก็แต่ถ้าตัดเลไม่แต่ถ้าตัดเล็บดูตัด
เล็บดูทีมันไม่ได้นะ
ตัดแบบนี้ตัดแบบนี้เหรอตัดตัดไปอ้าวนิ้ว
ไม่มีแล้วนะเพตัดนิ้วไป
แล้วอ๋อเค้าอาจจะตัดแล้วก็แบบเงยหน้าขึ้น
มาแล้วก็ไปตัด
อ๋อแล้วก็มีอะไรนะคูนี่คิดว่าถ้าทำหลายๆ
อย่างพร้อมกันมันจะต้องเป็นอะไร
ที่เรียกว่ายังไงดีที่มันต้องใช้เวลาแต่
ละอันยกตัวอย่างเหมือนอย่างของครูนิกครู
นิกไปในครัวอยากกินกาแฟคุณนี้ชงกาแฟอแล้ว
ก็พอชงกาแฟใช่มยมันก็จะใช้เวลาประมาณ 1
นาทีต้มน้ำร้อนพอเราต้มน้ำร้อนรอเวลา 1
นาทีเนี่ยเราก็ไปทำอย่าง
อื่นอืในระหว่าง 1 นาทีพอทำตรงนั้นเสร็จ
สมมุติคุนิกชงกาแฟคุณนนี้ไปต้มน้ำร้อนพอ
ต้มน้ำร้อนเสร็จแล้วก็อออ่ะมาซัก
ผ้าคนี้ก็ซักผ้าซักผ้าไปพอขยี้ผ้าไปได้ 2
ตัวอ้อ 1 นาทีแล้วไปเอาน้ำร้อนใส่กาแฟออ
ใส่กาแฟแล้วก็กินกาแฟเดินไปในห้องน้ำเอา
กาแฟวางไว้แล้วก็ซักผ้าต่อถ้าแบบนั้นน่ะ
คุณนคิดว่าได้อืแต่ว่ามันก็แบบมีการแบบ
สลับสลับหยุดโฟกัสอยู่เรื่อยๆเนาะใช่ใช่
อือูนิเรียมคิดอะไรออก
ละถ้าครูนิกเรียมนึกถึงครูนิกกำลังนอนอาบ
แดดอยู่อืแล้วอ่านหนังสือฟังเพลงแล้วถ้า
ครูนิกหยิบขนมมากินด้วยอืเออมันก็เพิ่มมา
เป็น 4 อย่างเลยนะมันก็เพิ่มใช่แต่ครูนิก
เนี่ยคือครูนิกจริงๆก็เคยลองนะแต่ครุณนิก
ก็จะรู้สึกว่ามันขนมเนี่ยไม่หมดอืเพราะ
ว่าครุณนิกก็จะไม่ค่อยได้สนใจละไอ้อย่าง
ที่ 4 เนี่ยคุณนี้ก็จะลืมไปเลยคืออาจจะ
กินนิดนึงพอกินนิดนึงแล้วก็ถ้าอร่อยคุณ
นี้ก็จะปิดหนังสือละอืแล้วก็กินพอกิน
เสร็จแล้วก็เออเริ่มง่วงนอนละแล้วก็หลับ
เลยอหลับแล้วก็พอตื่นมาอีกทีก็คือหลังครู
นิกเนี่ยดำละออเพราะว่าไม่ได้พลิก
โอโหแล้วในความคิดเห็นของครูนิคิดว่าทำ
อีกสิ่งนึงแล้วก็ทำอีกสิ่งนึงไปด้วยเนี่ย
มันดีหรือไม่ดีคือสำหรับครูนิกครูนิกคิด
ว่าดี
มยมันก็
อืมคุณนิจะใช้คำว่าไม่ดีละกันอืคือ
อันเนี้ยครูนิกครูนิกคิดเกี่ยวกับกับคุณ
นิคิดเวลาเราทำงานนะเพราะถ้าเราทำงานจริง
ๆเนี่ยในบริษัทหรือในที่ทำงานเราเนี่ยเขา
ก็จะบอกว่าเขาชอบคนที่ทำงานหลายๆอย่าง
พร้อมกันแต่สำหรับคุณสำหรับคุณนิกเนี่ย
คุณนิกคิดว่าถ้าทำหลายๆอย่างพร้อมกันแต่ง
งานมันไม่ดีอืมันไม่ดีเลยกับทำทีละอย่าง
แล้วงานดีทุกอย่างอืตอนนี้เรียมก็สอนไป
ด้วยอาบแดดไปด้วยแล้วตอนเนี้ยใช่อ่ะเห็น
มั้ยทำหลายอย่างพร้อมกันใช่ๆในมุมมองของ
เรียมก็แบบมีทั้ง 2 อย่างนะมีทั้งดีแล้ว
ก็ไม่ดี
อืไม่ดีก็คือแบบเออมันมันแบบโฟกัสไม่ได้
แล้วมันมันมันทำได้ไม่ดีมันทำไม่ได้แบบ
100% ในแต่ละอย่างแต่ว่าเรียมนึกถึงตอน
ที่เรียมไปออกกำลังกายครับออกกำลังกายไป
ด้วยฟังเพลงไปด้วยอันนั้นน่ะสำหรับเรียม
คือดีก็คือแบบเรียมจะไปสนุกกับเพลงแล้ว
แบบร่างกายมันก็ลืมว่ามันเหนื่อยอ่ะอืม
เออแต่พอครูเรียมพูดเนี่ยครูนิก็เป็น
เหมือนกันครูนิกชอบวิ่งแล้วครุณนิกอ่ะจะ
ต้องต้องฟังเพลงเพราะครูนิกอ่ะคิดว่าถ้า
ฟังเพลงเนี่ยเวลามันจะผ่านไปเร็ว
อือืแต่แบบนั้นน่ะูนิก็มาคิดได้ว่าจริงๆ
แล้วเวลาเราทำหลายอย่างพร้อม
กันเราอ่ะก็จะโฟกัสอย่างเดียวใช่แต่เราจะ
โฟกัสสิ่งที่เราชอบมากกว่ายกตัวอย่างว่า
เราชอบฟังเพลงเราชอบวิ่งแต่พออยู่ด้วยกัน
พอเราวิ่งแล้วเราฟังเพลง
ด้วยหัวเราอ่ะมันโฟกัสกับเพลงแล้วเพราะ
ว่าเราชอบเพลงมากมากกว่าทำให้เวลาวิ่งมัน
ไปเร็วขึ้นในหัวของเราใช่ใช่เราก็ปล่อย
ให้ร่างกายวิ่งเป็น
อัตโนมัติใช่แล้วเราก็สนุกกับการฟังเพลง
อืมใช่แต่ก็ครูนิกก็มาคิดได้อีกอันนึง
เพราะอันนี้เนี่ยเหมือนกับที่โรงเรียนครู
นิเ้าเคยเ้าจะมีเหมันเหมือนจะมีคลามีชั้น
เรียนเกี่ยวกับเขาคเรียกว่าอะไรนะ
จิตวิทยาอืมจิตวิทยาก็เหมือนกับเป็นการ
จิตวิทยาเราจะใช้คำว่ายังไงดี
คือคุณครูคุณครูเเข้ามาแล้วเขาก็บอกว่า
เดี๋ยวจะมีทดลองนะจะให้ลองทำเคก็เปรียบ
เทียบระหว่างคนคุยกัน 2 คนอันนั้นเป็นอัน
แรกกับอันที่ 2 คือคนคุยกันแต่แต่คนที่
ฟังเราพูดเนี่ยเล่นโทรศัพท์ไปด้วย
อ๋อฟังเราไปด้วยเล่นโทรศัพท์ไปด้วยแล้ว
เขาก็บอกว่าเนี่ยพอคนทำ 2 อย่างพร้อมกัน
แล้วมันมีผลว่าคนที่เล่นคนที่เล่น
โทรศัพท์เนี่ยเค้าอ่ะไม่โฟกัสสิ่งที่เรา
พูด
100% เพราะว่า
เค้าสมองเค้าหรือหัวเคเนี่ยอยู่ที่
โทรศัพท์โฟกัสที่โทรศัพท์มากกว่า
อือืโหก็แบบนี้นี่เองก็แบบเราก็ไปดูแล้ว
กันเนาะว่าอันไหนที่แบบทำแล้วมันดีแล้ว
อันไหนที่ทำแล้วก็ไม่ดีเราก็เรียมว่าทุก
คนก็แบบรู้ได้ด้วยตัวเองใช่ก็ครูนิคิดว่า
ถ้าเราทำอะไรหลายๆอย่างแล้วทำคนเดียวแล้ว
มันคนอื่นไม่รู้สึกว่ามันดีหรือไม่ดีก็ทำ
ได้แต่ถ้าเราอยู่กับคนอื่นหลายๆคนหรือ
อยู่กับเพื่อนถ้าทำหลายๆอย่างพร้อมกันก็
ต้องดูว่ามันโอเคมยอือืใช่ๆค่ะโอเคสำหรับ
วันนี้เราก็ได้แบบคุยกันเรื่องนี้เนาะที่
แบบทำสิ่งหนึ่งไปด้วยแล้วก็ทำสิ่งหนึ่งไป
ด้วยหรือว่าทำอะไรหลายๆอย่างพร้อมกันครับ
อือืแล้วมันเป็นยังไงก็จริงๆอยากรู้ว่า
นักเรียนน่ะชอบอะไรมากกว่าระหว่างถ้ำ 1
อย่างหรือทำหลายอย่าง
อืเตอนนี้เรียมก็ 2 อย่างแล้วเนี่ยอาบแดด
ไปครึ่งตัวละแต่ตอนนี้ไหล่ครูเรียม
เปลี่ยนสีแล้วนะใช่ครุนี้ืมเรืมต้องแบบไป
ทาครีมกันแดดหรือว่าทำอะไรสักอย่างออกจาก
ตรง
นี้
ใช่โอเคอ่ะเดี๋ยวให้ครูเรียมไปทาครีมกัน
แดดก่อนใช่เราค่อยกลับมาคุยกันใหม่ในคลิป
หน้าคกลับมาคุยกันใหม่ได้ครับโอเคใช่ค่ะ
สำหรับวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะครับบ๊ายบาย
ครับ